كثيرون راوا ان هناك رمزيه في همم
انتخاب رئيس وزراء من اصل هندي او تعيين
هذا رئيس الوزراء من اصل هندي هل تعتقد
انه الناخب في بريطانيا ستهم هذه الرمزيه
اكثر من ارتفاع نسب التضخم
فقط
واحده من اكبر هذه المسائل هو ان هناك
ضرائب خضراء ستضاف على موضوع الصافي وهذا
لا يعكس السوار
اهتماماتهم
30 30
حتى الدعم الاقتصاديه مثل همم
هم هم همم مثلا همم الدفعه الاتيه
الجنيهاتي على
السخانات الجديده
والانظمه التي تدفع اليها حكم حاليا ترفع
الضرائب فقط يرغب بان يرى من الحكومه ما
يعكس اهتمامات المواطنين
مشابه نفس الشيء السويده
محاوله تحقيق
30 وتركز على الاستقطاعات في الانفاقات
وكيف يستغل بعض الفرصه من البراك بدلا من
التحفيز من قبل الحكم الحاليه
في عدم رضا تقريبا
تعاطي
عديده لبعض يتحدث عن كيفيه توحيد الحزب
واستعاده الاعضاء الذين تركوه ولكنه هنالك
محادثه اخرى عن تشكيل حزب جديد
الطاقه وازمه الطاقه التي نشهدها حاليا
وكيف سنصلح الاضرار
وما وصلنا اليه الان مع الحرب داخل
اوكرانيا والحرب مع روسيا
هو بشكل اساسي
على اننا ما عدنا مستقل لينا في مصادر
الطاقه وهناك مصادر عديده فالطاقه التركيز
الاساسي الى عديدين وحتى الاقتصاد خلال
الشتاء القادم وفي المستقبل القريب
والداخله هيكليه
يبحثون عن الجماعات اخرى
الخاص داخل الحزب وحتى ما اطراف خارجيه
هنالك الكثيره من الاضطرابات والاعدام
الاستقرار
اساسيه
الهجره والطاقه كما ذكر وكذلك وكيف يمكننا
تفعيل وتحقيق
شيئ فقط
رفع الضرائب
ووضعيه العبايه السنوات الماضيه من عمليات
الاطفال على دفع الضرائب وهذا ما لا يرغب
به الشعب بشكل طبيعي الحزب سيتذكر